okay
so warner brothers dc behind the scenes
drama
just keeps getting more interesting i
think this is going to be our first
dedicated video of the strictly talking
about
ray fisher's situation just a quick
recap you probably already know this
um it's been circulating the media and
the entertainment news for a while now
if you're clicking on this video you're
probably already up to date on the fact
that ray fisher
made some allegations that joss whedon
displayed a lot of abusive behavior
on set for justice league and that
producers jeff johns and john
berg he claims that they threatened his
career so with that there was a tweet
that went out not long ago
from ray fisher that said after five
weeks of interviews with various cast
crew warner media has officially
launched an independent third party
investigation to get to the heart of the
toxic and abusive work environment
created during justice league reshoots
this
is a massive step forward i believe this
investigation will show that jeff johns
joss whedon john berg and others grossly
abused their power during the
uncertainty of att's merger with time
warner thank you warner media and att
for making strides to ensure a safer
workplace for all
and then the story got very interesting
yesterday
warner brothers is claiming that ray
fisher is not
i repeat not cooperating
with its justice league investigation
and denies recent allegations
in regards to walter hamada the current
head of dc
films on september 4th ray fisher put
out on twitter
so you can better understand how deep
this goes after speaking out about
justice league i received a phone call
from the president of dc films where and
he attempted to throw joss whedon and
john berg
under the bus in hopes that i would
relent
on jeff johns i will not
accountability over entertainment so
basically corner ray fisher walter
hamada is asking him
to you know ease up on the jeff john's
thing because we need jeff johns
you know he's also tied to our comics
okay here's what this article
goes on to say in july ray fisher's
representatives asked dc films president
walter hamada to talk to mr fisher about
his concerns during the production of
justice league the two had previously
spoken
when mr hamada asked him to reprise his
role as cyborg in warner brothers
upcoming flash movie together with other
members of the justice league so the
good news is the cyborg is supposed to
be
in the flash movie supposed to be as of
now in their july conversation mr fisher
recounted disagreements he'd had with
the film's creative team regarding his
portrayal of cyborg and complained that
his suggested script revisions were not
adopted
mr ramada explained that creative
differences are a normal part of the
production process and that a film's
writer director ultimately has to be in
charge
of these matters hence that's why we got
joss whedon's
justice league notably mr romana
also told mr fisher that he would
elevate his concerns to warner media so
they could conduct an investigation
at no time did mr hamada ever throw
anyone under the bus as mr fisher has
falsely claimed
or render any judgments about the
justice league production in which
mr hamada had no involvement since
filming occurred before
mr hamada was elevated to his current
position
so right now warner brothers
is saying that pretty much ray fisher is
lying about
him he's flat out lying while mr fisher
never alleged any actionable misconduct
against him
warner brothers nonetheless initiated an
investigation into the concerns he'd
raised about his character's portrayal
still not
satisfied mr fisher insisted that warner
media hire an
independent third party investigator
this investigator has attempted multiple
times to meet with mr fisher to discuss
his concerns but to date
mr fisher has declined to
speak to this investigator this comes
from warner brothers
oh my warner brothers remains committed
to accountability
and to the well-being of every cast and
crew member on each of its productions
it also remains committed to
investigating any specific incredible
allegation of misconduct
which thus far mr fischer has failed
to provide no you see unless some stuff
is like
if and if there was like text exchange
or or if or ray fisher had
audio audio or video recording this is
really hard [ __ ] to prove
so this is becoming a weird game of he
said she said with this whole thing with
uh warner brothers they're saying ray
fisher's lying
yeah like he's false or at least falsely
claiming but in other words he's
they're saying he's lying and then
they're on top of that saying
he's not even cooperating with the
investigation but
i mean it's not really a but i would say
however
however the thing that makes this i
imagine difficult on ray fisher's
side of things i believe ray fish i
currently believe ray fisher just i've
heard i've heard so many things about
john sweden
and jeff johns that like it's not it
seems
pretty unfathomable to imagine that they
were pretty yeah big [ __ ]
i think there is a good amount of
credibility to the idea that ray fisher
has
so much to he has an entire career to
lose like this is
a huge catapult for him that he could
easily
be blacklisted for and this is the
concern i have right now is that if
warner brothers is going after him are
we in a weird terrain now where
ray fisher is in jeopardy of losing his
contract with warner brothers
okay so we shot that this video
at 12 p.m i finished editing it i was
gonna publish
it at two o'clock so while it was
uploading i went to ray fisher's twitter
and i was like aw crap there was an
update from ray fisher
on this very situation they're in the
middle of me editing that i did not
become
uh made well aware of here's what
happened uh he said as one of two tweets
thank you for all the support and seeing
through wb pitchers desperate and
scatter shop
attempt to discredit me
to continue protecting those in power i
met with investigator via zoom on august
26th
below is an email i sent to my team and
sag after immediately after where he
said
hey crew just got off the line with the
investigator had to end the interview
early before going into detail with him
so he did talk with the investigator
he's definitely put on the case by
warner brothers pictures not warner
media his findings will go directly in
solida warner brothers pictures
legal he also had another person on the
line as a witness which you weren't made
aware of i told him i needed to have a
rep on the line of security for myself
he tried to keep me on the line but i
told him i would need to consult my team
before proceeding
can we jump on a call discuss soon best
ray
so he was just trying to protect himself
but it sounds like he was talking with
the investigator that's a pretty
in my opinion that's a pretty reasonable
thing
to be like well you know i should
probably have a rep on here for talking
this extensively about this shouldn't i
especially if you've got a witness
yeah yeah i i completely stand with ray
fisher on that
yeah one at all with ray fisher's
trending
independently that's funny and he said
uh it's also worth noting that i made it
clear to the world on august 21st so
that i would be vetting the investigator
to ensure a fair and protected process
for all witnesses
that's what we're talking about i don't
know if that's gonna be said after this
point i'm gonna go back to
what we shot earlier in just a minute
but
that's what we were talking about wb
pitchers has escalated this to an
entirely different level but i'm ready
to meet the challenge
wow so um ray fisher's calling them on
their [ __ ]
well yeah now you look back at their
statement and you're like is that what
they meant is
it not talking to investigators meaning
like i cancelled
you know going further with the calls so
that we could make these more
equitable [ __ ] damn this is crazy oh man
like yeah it alludes to some definite
spin from what wb just put
out who is lying i i believe ray fisher
i do
i do believe ray fisher said it two
hours ago
i'm still saying it now this is crazy
well i'm glad we caught this from the
way it's sounding is this is the last
time he talked with the investigator
yeah and then they he just hasn't
retouched base with them since and then
warner brothers puts out a statement
saying
he hasn't been uh cooperating he's flat
out said in that statement they've been
trying to talk with him
yeah and have an investigator speak with
him but he hasn't been he hasn't been
cooperating when he or he's saying no i
did speak with them
one yeah and you can look at what he
says even directly in that email and go
well
that is a form of not cooperating at the
moment
but a completely legitimate one you know
it makes it seem like yeah he's just
blocking the investigation not willing
to
even entertain who they want to send you
know to to
sift through all these details and i
mean he does have a point because he is
the person bringing this to the
forefront
i would understand him wanting to a vet
that person if possible and
b get some people around to make the
best decisions because this is a legal
matter now
well it sounds like the public is mainly
on his side right now anyway
back to what we shot earlier i'm super
excited for the snyder cut i especially
think that cyborg
portrayal was the thing that got duped
the most out of anything with the dc
universe
you're getting a flash movie aquaman was
a big hit ben affleck's coming back in
the flash movie
you know like there's a there's a lot of
great things the portrayal of cyborg
seems to be one of the main topics of
zack snyder's discussions around
that being the heart of the movie that
being the soul of the film oh i can't
wait to see more of what ray fisher has
to do
with the snyder cut it's weird because
warner brothers
is taking a very specific stand here
they're saying ray fisher's a not
cooperating
ray fisher lied that although it makes
me go
damn they're gonna fire this guy yeah
they're gonna let him go they're
going full guns blazing and yeah it
makes me have so many more questions
i can't imagine how this will work out
in a way where he's in the flash or
something like that
with full-on friction in the studio you
know it's it's
bizarre that they've put out a statement
about this yet they don't do anything
about ezra miller
i know and the other thing or amber
heard
you know yeah and the other thing about
all of this is it makes me also think
about just the rest of the cast and crew
because nobody has really
like everybody jumped on the snyder cut
train it seems like everybody was
for that and seemed to verify the
mishandling of that movie but nobody's
really jumped on with ray fisher or gone
after ezra
like everyone's pretty quiet on these
things so i'm also curious about
what their accounts of this would be
because theoretically everybody would
have had to work with
a joss whedon and be these producers
yeah i'm kind of surprised no one's
coming in to really help defend well
this
this is a scary terrain this actor ray
is going after
essentially something's going on people
who have
had a a an element of control over
the trajectory of his career so this is
a difficult position for him to be in
like i get why he doesn't even come out
and just be completely straightforward
about
everything that happened like only
dropping little hints in there because
he's talked about it before that because
of contract issues embargo issues or
things that he just cannot say
because think about it like this and
obviously this is all pure speculation
at this point he could land himself in a
situation of
i didn't have enough for all the
evidence just yet
the concern was being raised they're
investigating it but let's say the
investigator
comes and he's not fully prepared yet
they can go couldn't find anything
it's fine yeah we did our job we did it
yeah so i don't know if he's just like
they're knocking on his door
just like not home no yeah give me 10
more minutes
i swear it's around here somewhere come
back tomorrow
i'm concerned for the guy he's all over
that snyder cut trailer too
and i and he is yeah and i mean you know
this came also on the heels of
announcements that like hey
he's involved potentially with the flash
movie be not happy with the flash script
and that's another big topic is like uh
he doesn't like the flashcard or what
they're doing with this character
and like i don't know because on the one
hand yeah i mean like he was one of my
favorite parts of the frankenstein that
was joss whedon's justice league and i
am really excited to see him get better
characterization in the zack snyder
version but now i'm sitting here going
ray fisher is not like the guy who who
controls the dc universe and he seems
like i got curious about the earlier
part of these allegations where they're
talking about like ah he didn't like
that his
script notes weren't being taken and i'm
like how big does that figure in because
you know yeah it sucks but also you're
not the director you're not the
producers
you can give the script notes but if
they're not taken like that i don't know
is a form of abuse so i don't know like
where that fits into all this
are they trying to because i don't hear
ray fisher talk even
talking about that himself yeah i don't
hear him talking about yeah i read this
flash drive [ __ ] sucker i don't hear
him saying any of that
and that could be a smear campaign
that's what i mean it's like are they
trying to spin this to be like
ray fisher's just butt hurt because yeah
like his suggestions
it's this weird drama it's becoming
bizarre you think it'd be like kind of
straightforward at this point
david and goliath has so much murkier
circumstances yeah
the whole thing with the flash script
whatever this element
has me concerned for ray fisher's uh
career because
if they're like man this actor just
doesn't play ball with us this ain't
good you know
um that's the concern i mainly have at
this point with ray fisher but right now
this is uh
i'm kind of worried i'm kind of scared
for the guy not in the sense of
what he's doing is wrong it's that oh
crap he's one guy and there's a whole
team of people who are now going after
them they can destroy you in so many
ways yeah you can easily
pick one man spin a wheel i feel like
this will come down to two things it's
like this could really hurt his career
but
if he's the real deal and that comes to
light he'll be fine someone will want to
work with him someone will catch his
phone
if this is proven to be a lot of smoke
over nothing
then i don't think he'll work with
anybody yeah that's true or he'll work
on you know bad
and low-budget movie alright guys well
what do you think about this piece of
news leave your thoughts down below
you siding with ray fisher at the end of
the day i believe in the principle of
accountability over entertainment
sounds like warner brothers is preaching
the same thing right now yeah
now who's this moroccan i just want good
movies man
i just want to enjoy my movies we just
want to go watch a fake
fantasy for two hours that's it this is
crazy it's going to be this horrible dc
fandom's like the greatest event this
whole year
and i'm like no it's about all this
drama are all these movies made of toxic
lies
come on guys uh we'll still watch every
one of them
yeah all right guys subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell last but not least
anissa oliva anissa i got to give a
special shout out to this homegirl right
now because
for my birthday she coordinated and
edited put together this video where she
got a whole bunch of people from the
our real rejects discord say some really
really complimentary sweet things my way
video brought me to tears
anissa i love the hell out of you i know
you had a pretty big scary situation to
deal with these last couple weeks i'm
glad that's getting a lot better
in your personal life but really you
mean a hell of a lot to me there are
certain people at our patreon especially
where i don't have enough words to
properly
compartmentalize just how much you mean
to me
and you are one of them undoubtedly
seriously i love the hell out of you
you're incredibly sweet
and um you've impacted my life in more
ways than you could ever imagine
thank you for being you hope we continue
to entertain the hell out of you and
let's just stay connected forever and
ever
forever ever at the gas station
yep
[Music]
you